there is a Demon Slayer who uses a
double-barreled shotgun instead of a
sword and who has the ability to eat the
Flesh of demons in order to gain the
physical powers of a demon in battle by
the end of this video you will know
everything you need to know about gen
yashi nezugawa the younger brother of
the wind hashidasanami and one of the
most unique and memorable demon Slayers
in history Kenya has actually been
around since the very first Arc of the
story but he really gets a chance to
shine during the swordsmith village Arc
so let's get into it
you guys know the drill if you enjoy our
Demon Slayer content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it only takes you
a second but it helps me out a lot with
that YouTube algorithm and of course if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is completely free but it
helps us out a lot genya was born into a
family of seven children so it was him
his older brother sonami and five other
siblings their mother was a very short
and petite woman and she worked
extremely hard from morning until night
Kenya never even remembers seeing her
sleep that's how hard she worked for her
family but while their mother was great
their father was just the opposite he
was an extremely large man who beat his
wife and children even though their
mother was much smaller than their
father she always did her best to Shield
her children from their father's attacks
and she would often absorb his cruel
beatings with her own body genya's
mother was a hero to him and his father
was a monster his father was eventually
killed in the street by one of the many
people who hated him because of the kind
of man he was he might have been someone
he wronged or someone he owed money to
or just someone who didn't like him for
whatever reason Kenya and sanami felt
that their father got exactly what he
deserved and after that their mother
worked hard to provide for her family
while ganya and Sunami did their best to
take care of their other siblings but
then one night their mother didn't come
home from work the kids became concerned
because she had never been out so late
and sonami went out to look for her
however before sanami could return a
demon broke into the house and attacked
the shinesugawa siblings the Demon's
attacks killed genia's brothers and
sisters and it was during this attack
that he picked up that large scar on his
face at first Kenya was confused about
what was even happening and he thought
thought that a wolf had forced its way
inside his house thankfully before Kenya
was also killed sonomi arrived he
engaged the demon in combat while
telling Genia to run away sonomi then
forced the demon out into the street and
continued to fight there back inside the
house ganya was still in utter shock and
disbelief about what happened and he
told his siblings to just put pressure
on their wounds and hang in there even
though they were all already dead Kenya
was in a state of pure shock and his
brain simply couldn't accept the reality
of the situation eventually he ran out
into the street to look for a doctor who
could help his siblings but as he rushed
through the street he came across a
blood-soaked sonomi holding a Cleaver
lying on the ground by sanami's feet was
their mother she was covered in blood
and she wasn't moving she was dead genya
began to cry and as he held his mother's
body in his arms he screamed at sonemi
he asked why sonomi would kill their
mother like this and he called his own
brother a murderer but that's because at
the time Genia just couldn't accept the
terrible truth the so-called wolf that
he saw attacking him and his siblings
was not a wolf at all it was a demon and
it was not just any demon it was their
own mother who had been turned into a
demon and who then came back to her
family home to attack her own children
now from everything that we know about
her as a human she would never do this
intentionally so clearly being turned
into a demon changed her completely and
made her lose her mind and attack her
own children basically I don't think we
could hold this against her as a person
because she wasn't in control of her own
actions sonimi didn't even realize who
he was fighting at first and he only
learned The Tragic Truth as the fight
moved outside and into the light of dawn
to this day Kenya feels terrible for his
brother and how he must have felt having
to kill his own mother in that way after
their father died sonami had vowed that
he and genya would protect the family
together and that they would defend
their mother and their younger siblings
and then he went through such a tragic
experience he was forced to kill his own
mother after she became a demon and
killed his siblings and then after all
of that genya sanami's last remaining
sibling screamed at him angrily and
called him a murderer ganya has always
regretted how he behaved towards his
brother and he is determined to become a
hashira in order to one day earn his
brother's respect and forgiveness after
the demon attack sonomi abandoned his
younger brother and dedicated himself to
hunting down demons at first he didn't
even know that the demon Slayers existed
and he didn't know about nitrogen blades
either so he just used whatever weapons
he could find he would locate demons
trap and immobilize them and then wait
for the sun to come out and burn them
sandami's actions were so wild and
Reckless that he later thought that he
might have been subconsciously trying to
end his own life but he was lucky that
he possessed an extremely rare and
special blood type called marichi this
blood type is especially intoxicating to
demons and it distracts them and slows
them down which allowed sonami to get
the jump on them during one of his demon
hunts he met a Demon Slayer called
masachika kumeno and this Demon Slayer
recruited tsunami into the Demon Slayer
core but unlike sanami genya didn't have
any impressive natural abilities and he
was never able to learn a breathing
style out of pure desperation genya
decided to take a different route to
gaining strength he began eating the
Flesh of demons which allowed him to
temporarily attain the physical
constitution of a demon including their
superhuman strength and regeneration
abilities genya's one natural Talent was
his unusually strong jaw and his unique
digestive system which made it possible
for him to eat and digest demon flesh
and that is exactly what he decided to
do do when he eats demon flesh genya
attains a demonic form in which he grows
fangs and in which the whites of his
eyes turn black he is the only person in
the entire Demon Slayer core who is able
to do this although in the past there
were a few others who had this ability
we know of at least one other Demon
Slayer who was able to do this but he
lived over 300 years ago we first meet
Kenya during the first Arc of the Demon
Slayer Story the final selection Arc
where he is one of the people who
survives the seven day trial along with
tanjiro kanaw and zenitsu there was of
course a fifth person who passed the
trial inosuke but he is not shown until
later when the other four meet with two
ubuyashiki children after the trials are
completed genya is extremely irritable
impatient and violent and he demands to
be given a color-changing Katana right
away he physically swats away his Crow
and then he actually hits the
eight-year-old Kanata ubayashiki and
grabs her hair demanding akatana
immediately tanjiro grabs genya's arm
and threatens to break it if he doesn't
let go of Kanata and when he doesn't
tanjiro really goes on to break genia's
forearm needless to say this is not the
best first impression for Kenya and
throughout the next few arcs we only get
brief Snippets of genya and in all of
them he is very rude and standoffish we
don't really get to understand genya's
character until the swordsmith village
Arc quick warning I can't really explain
the full extent of genya's powers
without including spoilers for The
swordsmith Village Arc and Beyond so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned as I mentioned earlier by
eating the living flesh of a demon genya
is able to temporarily gain the physical
characteristics of a demon the extent of
the Demonic power that genya gains
depends on the strength of the demon
whose flesh he consumes if he eats a
weaker demon he will still gain some
demonic abilities like the ability to
regrow a lost tooth or the ability to
recover from wounds that would have
incapacitated a regular human but genya
is at his strongest when he consumes the
Flesh of upper Moon demons which he
manages to do twice during the
swordsmith village Arc he consumes the
wood created by zohakuten one of the
upper Moon Four hunting Goose demon
forms and later on in the story he
consumes the hair and sword of
kokushible who is the strongest upper
Moon upper Moon one after consuming the
wood generated by zohakuten genya's
strength and speed increase drastically
and he is able to rip out entire trees
from the ground and throw them at
Huntington goo one after the other later
on in the story during the battle
against kokushible ganya is able to fire
bullets at kokushibo that transform into
powerful demonic trees upon impact these
trees look similar to the tree creatures
that zohakuten creates and they are able
to warp themselves around kokushibo and
temporarily bind him in place it is
likely that this ability to create
demonic trees stems from the fact that
genya consumed zohakuten's flesh much
earlier implying that even though the
effects of genya's demon eating are
temporary some aspects of the flesh he
consumes remain inside him and are able
to manifest again at a later date genya
is at his absolute strongest when he
manages to eat flesh that belongs to
Upper Moon one kokushi boat the
strongest demon in the world after muzon
himself genya becomes so powerful that
even after his body is literally cut in
two he is able to reattach his body
parts and regenerate them in just a few
seconds he also gains the ability to
hear muzan's telepathic instructions to
kokushibu later when genya also consumes
some of kokushibu's demonic sword
ganya's appearance begins to take on
more of kokushibu's characteristics and
he is able to withstand even the most
severe wounds including the loss of his
head without dying he is also able to
create a demonic flesh gun in a similar
way that kokushibu creates his demonic
flesh sword and this flesh gun leads to
the development of genya's very own
blood demon art genya is able to control
the direction and velocity of the
bullets that he fires from his flashcard
meaning that he can literally manipulate
them and force them to move around
corners and other obstacles in order to
hit their intended target directly this
makes his bullets practically impossible
to avoid and once they enter the Flesh
of the particular demon that Gena is
targeting they will then turn into trees
that will entangle and trap the demon
these demonic flesh bullets that genya
uses also have the ability to drain the
target's demon blood which prevents them
from effectively activating their blood
demon art it is important to note that
because Kenya's battle strategy requires
him to take on the physical attributes
of demons he can also be injured by
attacks that are targeted specifically
at demons such as nezuko's blood demon
art genya is also able to perform a
technique called repetitive action which
he learned from the stone hashira gyome
himejima essentially you repeatedly
perform a predetermined action such as a
religious chant in order to heighten
your concentration to the extreme and
this enables you to fully open up all
five of your senses you then summon a
memory of anger or pain which increases
your heart rate and body temperature
allowing you to draw out the full
physical powers of your body shifting
back and forth from repetitive action to
exerting your full strength allows you
to perform form a superhuman physical
feat such as moving a giant boulder this
technique is separate from breathing
Styles but some Demon Slayers are able
to use both techniques at the same time
which helps them unlock the Demon Slayer
Mark and maintain it for a longer period
of time initially even genya's best
efforts to repair the relationship
between him and his brother fail to bear
fruit and sanami appears to have no
interest in reconnecting with genya
sanami tells genya that he doesn't
consider scum like him to be his brother
and that ganya should just quit the
Demon Slayer core sonomi believes that
someone who can't even use breathing
Styles cannot become a hashira and
eventually he tells genya that if he
doesn't quit the Demon Slayer core he
sanami will personally kill ganya
nevertheless we later learned that
sanami behaved this way because he
wanted his brother to lead the Demon
Slayer core so that he could have a
normal family and live a normal life
sanami tried so hard to discourage his
brother from being a Demon Slayer
because he didn't want him to Die Young
at the hands of a demon eventually the
two brothers are able to repair their
relationship and they both fight
valiantly in the epic battle against
upper Moon 1 during the infinity Castle
Arc so let me ask you what is your
honest opinion of Kenya does his
backstory and character development make
up for the absolutely horrible first
impression he gives off at the beginning
of the story do you like how the story
ends for genya and sanami let me know
down in the comments and if you're
looking for an epic Demon Slayer video
to watch next don't miss my full
breakdown of the strongest Demon Slayer
ever yorichi tsugikuni and all of his
many powers and abilities Link in the
description and on screen if you enjoyed
this demonstrator video and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like right now and if you're one of the
over 50 of people who watch our videos
but haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a quick favor right now and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications